[Musique]
il faut intox avec Anthony Saint-Léger
Anthony bonsoir on va s'intéresser on
s'intéresser avec vous ce soir à des
fausses informations qui nous viennent
du Kenya à propos de l'armée ou gandaise
elle font suite à des déclarations du
fils du président ougandais
voilà dites vous allez nous en dire un
petit peu plus effectivement on va
commencer avec deux mots de contexte
d'abord justement pour bien comprendre
tout ça le 3 octobre fils du président
Ouganda est le général
mukosikanerogaba que l'on voit ici a eu
ses propos sur Twitter mon armée et moi
cela ne nous prendrait pas plus de deux
semaines pour capturer Nairobi la
capitale kenyan donc et le général de
continuer ensuite sur ce sur Twitter non
sans amusement d'évoquer par exemple des
noms de quartiers de la capitale qui
pourrait être occupé et de préciser même
qu'il pourrait se promener avec son
épouse alors cet humour n'a pas vraiment
fait rire les autorités kenyane
évidemment mais également son père le
président moussevini qui a qu'il a un
peu rappelé à l'ordre et pour cause il
l'a démis de ses fonctions de
commandement de commandant des forces
terrestres ou gandaises il a évidemment
présenté ses excuses au voisin Kenyans
et il a précisé lundi qu'il demandait à
son fils de quitter en tout cas de
s'abstenir de tout commentaire lié à des
affaires politiques et de préférer par
exemple le sport et c'est donc dans ce
contexte que des internautes gagnants ce
sont moqués de l'armée ou gandaise en
utilisant une vidéo bien précise oui
vidéo que voici regardez on y voit des
parachutistes ratés il faut dire il faut
dire ce qui est leur atterrissage il y a
il y en a deux vous allez voir celui de
droite qui va s'écraser dans dans la
foule et celui de gauche qui va
s'écraser un petit peu plus loin dans ce
qui s'apparente à des toilettes
provisoires des parachutistes ou Gandais
affirment les internautes qui partagent
ces images et pour ceux qui relaient ils
l'assure ce sont donc des parachutistes
ou gandels lors de la cérémonie de
commémoration des 60 ans de
l'indépendance de l'Ouganda cette vidéo
elle a été associée à de nombreuses
moqueries sur les réseaux sociaux
Kenyans des internautes qui ont ironisé
sur la puissance de l'armée ou gandaise
comme cette ancien sénateur Kenyans ce
sont des parachutistes ougandais ce sont
donc eux qui sont censés prendre Nairobi
en une semaine ironiser donc ce cet
ancien sénateur et puis cet autre
internaute se voilà comment c'est
parachutistes en Ouganda ont atterri le
jour de l'indépendance ils feront de
même pour atterrir anérobie là c'est la
moquerie signé d'un avocat gagnant et
cette scène Anthony pourtant elle n'a
pas été filmée en Ouganda et non on va
mener ensemble une petite recherche
d'images inversée assez rapide et elle
nous mène cette recherche d'images
inversée un article en espagnol un
article de presse un article d'un
journal ondulien on est en septembre
2022 elle est bien question
d'indépendance mais pas de celle mais de
l'Honduras les 201 ans très précisément
on retrouve d'ailleurs dans le corps de
cet article une des photos de la scène
dont dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
avec cette légende la chute enfin la
chute spectaculaire dans les gradins
d'un parachutiste on va aller un petit
peu plus loin en ce qui concerne la
recherche avec cette fois une recherche
Google et trois mots clés en espagnol
ont dû rase par la suite et 2022 cela
nous mène à une vidéo en espagnol une
vidéo CNN que l'on va découvrir ensemble
alors non pas la vidéo mais la capture
d'écran voilà et ce titre qui nous dit
donc des parachutistes tombent sur la
foule durant les célébrations de du Jour
de l'Indépendance donc de on dira cette
capture d'écran nous intéresse on va
pouvoir la comparer avec une autre de la
vidéo virale que l'on voit ici et
regarder il s'agit bien de la même scène
prise sous un angle différent on
reconnaît ici le parachute en question
que se retrouve ici parmi la foule il y
a aussi le profil de cette scène et de
cette structure que l'on retrouve ici
dans son entièreté et puis des gens
habillés en jaune et vert que l'on
retrouve également ici alors le partage
de assez viral de cette publication de
cette vidéo que l'on a vu tout à l'heure
associé aux mauvais contexte a fait
réagir évidemment les autorités
ougandaises et plus précisément le
porte-parole de la défense ougandaise
qui a bien qualifié et qualifié par dont
cette vidéo de fake news précisé qu'il y
avait bien eu des commémorations de
l'indépendance de l'Ouganda des 60 ans
le 9 octobre plus précisément et il
attirait l'attention sur la couleur des
parachutes en question qui ont été
montrées lors de ces commémorations et
on va ensemble jeter un coup d'oeil
justement et bien ils étaient de cette
couleur bleu et jaune pour certains ou
encore rouge et noir pour d'autres donc
rien à voir avec ce qu'on a pu voir en
endurance et puis la physionomie des
lieux également puisque là c'est là où
avait lieu les cérémonies de
commémorations d'indépendance Ouganda
donc une vaste piste avec des gradins là
ou pour l'onduras il s'agissait d'un
stade beaucoup donc de réactions
vis-à-vis de cela et j'en terminerai
là-dessus toute cette humour du fils du
président moussevini a généré pas mal de
d'enfance du côté des réseaux sociaux
Kenyans comme celle-ci par exemple une
vidéo où on voit un homme présenté comme
étant le président moussevénie jouant à
des arts martiaux de manière assez
maladroite il faut voir il s'agit en
fait d'un sketch d'un comédien je vous
renvoie sur le site des Observateurs de
France 24 pour connaître un peu plus les
dessous de cette infox merci beaucoup
Anthony Saint-Léger on peut retrouver
bien sûr votre chronique sur notre site